The key takeaway from the example we just went through is that we want
to split our aggregatable data and our descriptive data into separate tables.
This allows us to remove the duplicate data,
and then use the keys to create relationships between the tables.
All of this allows us to greatly reduce the amount of
repeat data and thus improve the efficiency of our data model.
There is some specific vocabulary that goes along with this.
The tables that hold our descriptive data,
we call dimension tables.
The tables that hold our aggregatable data,
we call fact tables.
Let's talk about the key characteristics of dimension tables and fact tables.
Dimension tables store descriptive data,
like data describing that a particular product is
a specific variety of apple or that
a particular date occurred in the month of February and so on.
Dimension tables tend to be short and fat.
The reason they tend to be fat is because we often need a lot of
columns to provide all the descriptive information we need.
We may want to say that a product is a fruit.
That is an apple,
that it is a specific variety of data.
We may want to give the product size and so on.
The table can get very wide or fat with all the descriptive columns added.
But we don't repeat that descriptive data.
That's why the dimension tables tend to be short.
We only need a single row to describe each unique item.
In contrast, fact tables are used to store aggregatable data.
They tend to be long and thin.
For example, with a sales data,
we can have many transactions in which
different customers purchase the same type of apple.
The fact table for sales data will get longer and longer as we make more sales.
With both dimension tables and fact tables,
we need to have a key.
This is how we create a relationship linking the two tables so that we can
do things like looking up all the sales that meet a particular product description.
Fact tables and dimension tables are a core concept in data modeling.
We'll get lots of practice working with them as we go through this course.